[Musique]
aujourd'hui on va parler de la surface
gow2 microsoft c'était un petit moment
que j'ai envie de vous en parler on va
enfin pouvoir avancer sur la question
alors on va tester on à la souris qui va
bien avec on a le style et qui juste là
on a bien évidemment le clavier surface
signature type cover pour surface d'eau
qui est juste là et on a à l'intérieur
le saint graal pour la vache ses lois
une la surface groupe donc ce qu'on va
faire c'est qu'on va l'ouvrir on a
regardé ce qu'à l'intérieur on va
regarder comment elle marche on va
regarder ce qu'on peut faire avec qui on
va se poser la question si on doit
acheter une tablette tablette gèle pas
trop le terme dans la mesure où doit
acheter ce type de format est ce qu'il
vaut mieux aller sur une surface go ou
sur un ipad mon avis la réponse est
parce que toute trouvée on va voir avant
toute chose
j'ai reçu une énorme carton de philips
avec deux choses à l'intérieur alors
voir ce qui est dedans alors qu'est ce
qu'on a à l'intérieur un petit message
d'attention d'aurélien bonjour bienvenue
de notre communauté you voici nos
basiques ue afin de vivre une belle
expérience lumineuse connectés bonne
découverte en espérant te voir le 6 au 7
octobre à paris pour notre escale games
for light l'équipe philippe sion merci
philippe sioux alors qu'est ce qu'on a à
l'intérieur un joli sac
philip sion qu'est ce que c'est que ça
je pense une lampe collecter on étudiera
soit plus en détail un peu plus tard on
a ici à sa petite soeur ça c'est cool on
a ici
un starter kit starter kit avec des
ampoules philippe schuth assez génial ça
c'est quoi ça light is dead des leds mon
avis l'aide ça c'est quoi
sensiblement la même chose à vérifier
ensuite ça c'est des accessoires pour
piloter je suppose la même chose
accessoires d'attac motion sensor cool
et on a un style aux philippines merci
philippe sion on va donc se concentrer
maintenant sur la surpasse go j'en ai
déjà parlé il ya quelques temps
lorsqu'elle a été annoncé sa mère est
une solution qui est vraiment hyper
intéressante j'ai testé ya pas très
longtemps la surface pro je sais pas si
vous avez vu la vidéo c'est pas le cas
vous invite à laisser un petit coup
d'oeil ça vient d'être une bécane qui
est vraiment top donc on va les tester
on va regarder un petit peu ce qu'on
peut faire avec
puis je vous ferai mon retour à la fin
voilà la boîte up surface go déjà on
arrive directement sur le produit
laurent et y aller doucement pour pas
tout jeter tous les côtés ce qui est
d'ailleurs la spécialité j'adore jolie
format hyper prévenir alors on a bien
évidemment si vous connaissez la grande
surface
vous pouvez l'ouvrir pour la poser comme
vous le souhaitez vous pouvez l'ouvrir
davantage pour la pesée en gwada plus
tablette foule à régler comme vous
voulez pour bosser ça c'est vraiment une
spécificité de la gamme surface et je
trouve ça vraiment superbe d'avoir cette
partie là l'arrière qui est très
flexible
c'est vraiment de le caler comme vous
voulez de faire ce que vous voulez mais
c'est vraiment superbe outil microsoft
surface ghost de documentation qui
explique un petit peu le guide de
démarrage comment ça se passe voilà ça
c'est cool on a ici ensuite bien ça doit
être les charges
mon avis c'est ça bloc d'alimentation
s'écoule comme c'est fait bloc
d'alimentation pour notre surface go on
a ensuite ici la petite souris le
surface pen qui est juste là j'adore et
on a ici le clavier en alcantara
signature type cover enfin contre le
connecter c'est super simple vous avez
en dessous sur votre surface go la
connectique là vous le présenter en face
ça s'aimantent savez tout seul trouver
son chemin vous le refermer et ça vous
fait votre petit à petit le ch pas si
pape et sa tablette tablettes
ordinateurs deux en un directement fermé
donc ça c'est cool
ça fait plusieurs jours que je teste
cette surface go maintenant il est temps
de vous donner un petit peu mon verdict
est vraiment ce que j'adore je vois si
vous avez vu ces windows des logements
si vous connaissez windows et l'eau
c'est un peu le faith and faith and i
liked en tout cas de microsoft c'est à
dire que vous éteignez vous rallumer
savuth cannes directement le visage ça
vous reconnais bonjour monsieur heureux
monsieur groupe bim bam boum c'est parti
on démarre donc vous avez plusieurs
possibilités là dessus que je trouve
vraiment cool là dedans c'est l'aspect
visuel
j'enlève tous les accessoires j'ai
l'aspect visuel g dans la main une
tablette si vous connaissez la gamme
surface de microsoft vous saurez quand
ça s'arrête pas là vous avez la
possibilité de l'ouvrir comme ça hop
vous pouvez incliner vous vous inclinez
jusqu'à 165 degrés ça c'est vraiment
génial parce que ça vous permet
effectivement de l'utiliser comme une
tablette pour pouvoir la poser pour
pouvoir regarder des films des vidéos
pouvoir bosser avec votre stylet mais ça
je vais le détail dans quelques instants
mais ce qui est aussi super c'est que
lorsque vous voulez dessinée que vous
mettez dessus vous le positionner
vraiment bas et vous pouvez dessiner
façon plus naturelle sans qu'ils soient
apaisés complètement à plat ou tout de
suite ça va être un petit peu moins
sympa vous mettez l'angle que vous
voulez à grâce au pied et ça pour moi
c'est vraiment génial
d'autant plus que vous avez un cadre qui
est entièrement fait en magnésium donc
hyper cailly hyper léger très robuste
rien que pour ça j'adore le design je
trouve vraiment sublime la caméra à
l'arrière on va le détail aussi d'ici
quelques instants le logo ici microsoft
que je trouve super extrêmement facile à
manier à manipuler à ouvrir ça sent la
robustesse ça c'est quand même plutôt
cool ça c'est le point positif pour le
design maintenant pour un peu négatif
pour le design lorsque je regarde comme
ça lorsque vous l'ouvrez hello hello
monsieur heureux c'est les grands
contours noirs les grandes bordure noire
c'est une problématique technique vous
permettre d'insérer les différents
capteurs en eau pour insérer votre
caméra et pour avoir une
proportionnalité
bon là dessus il n'ya pas système
d'encore façon les encoches ça serait
compliqué sur une tablette parce que
vous pouvez tourner dans différents
censé avoir différentes configurations
ce n'est pas particulièrement adaptés
s'il doit y avoir un point négatif d'un
point de vue purement esthétique ça
reste quand même ce grand contours noirs
parce que c'est vrai que sinon j'ai
globalement rien à lui reprocher en plus
ce que je trouve vraiment cool sur cette
surface go vous avez votre connectique
est ou qui est là
pour la recharger c'est la connectique
propriétaire de microsoft mais en plus
et ce qui est vraiment bien
ils vous ont intégré ici un port en usb
type c alors à quoi ça va vous servir
ça va vous servir par exemple à
connecter des petits travel doc
lorsque vous allez être en déplacement
typiquement là je vous emprunt que j'ai
présenté l'autre jour c'est le travel
docks de targus vous le prenez vous le
plus gai directement là dessus en usb
tilt c'est hélas vous avez toute une
myriade de connectique avec du port vga
qui est si avec du hdmi donc vous pouvez
vous câble et à un moniteur extérieur un
vidéoprojecteur vous avez aussi de l'usb
de l'usb tic c'est un port ethernet
enfin il ya pas mal de choses
ça permet vraiment d'étendre les
possibilités avec cet outil et ça en
tout cas
franchement c'est super cool de la part
mis là dessus autre point extrêmement
positif selon moi c'est la présence du
port jack
lorsque vous voulez brancher un casque
je sais que le pan jack disparaît
énormément mais ils seront ça vraiment
bien que microsoft est resté là dessus
ça c'est aussi un point très positif
merci microsoft sinon vous retrouver son
côté si vos petits boutons pour monter
des sept volumes votre bouton ici pour
l'allumer pour l'éteindre et bien
évidemment ici le petit endroit pour
venir brancher votre clavier signature
type cover justement ce clavier
parlons-en
vous avez en option le clavier surface
type cover un accessoire qu'il faut
acheter en plus et c'est à mon avis un
des points faibles de cet objet lorsque
vous achetez votre surface go vous avez
votre tablette qui est là tout seul et
qui vous coûte en version 64 giga + 4
gigas de ram 449 euros la vue 99 et en
version 8 gigas de ram 128 go de
stockage à ça c'est la version que j'ai
ici 599 euros 99
lorsque vous voulez l'utiliser je dirais
dans la version la plus complète il vous
faut forcément acheter en plus le
clavier qui vous coûte quand même la
modique somme de 130 euros en liquide
mais il est là parce que je vais vous
faire en démonstration dans quelques
instants
en plus de ça et ce qui est vraiment
indispensable là dessus c'est d'acheter
le petit stylet qui vous coûte quand
même 110 euros et à ça vous rajouter
ensuite le petit mulot la petite souris
qui vous coûte 30 euros
je vous laisse faire le calcul vous
rajoutez 110 euros
vous rajoutez 130 euros et vous rajouter
30 euros et vous avez un ensemble
complet à 869 euros 99
mais malgré la question du prix ça
fonctionne vraiment très très très bien
j'ai testé il ya pas très longtemps la
surface pro j'étais vraiment extrêmement
surpris parce que pour moi c'était une
découverte et là c'est pareil vient
trouver sa position tout seul alors
effectivement il faut l'ouvrir un paf
l'afld vous la poser comme ça vous avez
si votre petit clavier vous le relevez
il se positionne tout naturellement ça
pour moi c'est vraiment génial
vous posez vos doigts dessus vous avez
un petit temps que ça vous évite de
casser les poignets c'est vraiment
extrêmement génial ce clavier bien
cerner très très facilement vous l'avez
comme ça pour moi c'est vraiment la
sorte est génial parce que d'une ça vous
le protège lorsque vous leur demandez
placement opp
il est fermé salles met en veille ça
reconnaît qu'il a été éteint donc ça
c'est vraiment génial il ya une vraie
protection plus c'est vraiment très très
doux c'est de l'alcantara
c'est plutôt bien point positif je vous
dis ok vous le prenez vous le posez vous
le mettez comme ça vous l'emmenez où
vous voulez vous faites ce que vous
voulez et là il devient un vrai
ordinateur de bureau
et ça pour moi c'est juste topissime en
plus de ça vous avez un vrai retour sur
les touches lorsque vous l'utilisez il
est très très très agréable le côté
extrêmement doux ici de l'alcantara
rajoute vraiment à la qualité du produit
donc rien que pour ça ce clavier une
fois de plus est vraiment super bien et
je vous le dis il se manipule
extrêmement facilement autres
accessoires super cool
le stylet pour moi là dessus le style et
c'est tout sauf une option il réagit
extrêmement bien vous pilotez votre
tablette extrêmement facilement alors
après on n'a pas la même précision que
j'ai retrouvée sur une surface pro
néanmoins pour une utilisation un peu
standard ça marche super bien il vous
permettra par exemple de faire des
petits dessins tout simple vraiment
sympa là typiquement hop je fais des
petits coloriage à la cool c'est pas
quelque chose de très très compliqué on
va pas avoir la même précision que sur
la surface prône néanmoins ça fera
extrêmement bien à faire vous pouvez
vous retrouver à écrire très facilement
fin je trouve que pour moi la qualité
est là pour moi là dessus j'ai vraiment
rien à lui reprocher le stylet vous
apporte aussi un confort pour naviguer
sur le web
c'est vraiment un outil qui est très
sympa extrêmement actif ça va très très
vite pour la prise de notes
il marche super bien alors moi j'écris
extrêmement mal donc forcément la
qualité
vous allez dire mais qu'est ce que c'est
que ça dans sa ville justement ne m'en
voulez pas mais bon
c'est comme ça on se corrige pas c'est
pas faute d'avoir fait des cahiers
d'écriture étant gamin jusqu'à très
longtemps comme quoi ça ne sert
strictement à rien donc pour la faire
simple le combo surface go clavier et
stylé marche très bien d'autant plus que
le stylet est aimanté vous le posez là
comme sur la surface plutôt cool mais il
me semble qu'il ya nos accessoires qui
se trouvent juste là ces petits boulots
la souris c'est un peu l'accessoire en
plus pour vous permettre de l'utiliser
comme un vrai ordinateur vous avez votre
souris votre petite molette bien
évidemment pour venir naviguer tout
simplement bon c'est très classique qui
gauche clic droit
vous l'utilisez sur votre windows 10 et
ça marche extrêmement bien d'un point de
vue esthétique elle est forcément moins
sympa c'est vous allez pouvoir retrouver
sur la surface pro vous allez venir plié
en deux la cie vous amuser à la pliant
de vous allez l'exploser mais bon après
tout pourquoi pas vous faites ce que
vous voulez avec la surface go on a donc
un ordinateur clavier souris
on a donc également une tablette
graphique prise de notes avec votre
stylet vous avez aussi juste une
tablette comme ça ce qui fait qu'au
final cet objet n'est pas du tout un
objet classique
c'est vraiment un hybride c'est un
hybride entre un ordinateur une tablette
une tablette graphique et au milieu de
tout ça c'est à vous trouvez votre
utilisation
mais là où le bât blesse un petit peu au
niveau de cette bécane c'est la
puissance vous avez un processeur intel
pentium goal 4415 y
alors il fera la faire franchement il
fera la faire pour quasiment toutes vos
tâches c'est à dire que vous avez
utilisé pour de la bureautique pour
aller sur instagram vous regardez des
vidéos sur netflix sur youtube pour
écouter de la musique
l'explosif haye ou autres pour faire
quelques petits jeux mais vraiment pas
gourmand n'espérez pas faire tourner un
fortnight un pur bijou des choses comme
ça là dessus ça ne tournera pas ça ne
suffira pas mais pour tout ce qui va
être une utilisation bureautique prise
de notes dessins des choses comme ça
qu'ils vont pas être trop gourmande
il ira parfaitement bien si vous avez
besoin d'un regain de puissance c'est là
où effectivement la machine va être un
petit peu plus limité d'autant plus
qu'il y a deux configurations une
configuration avec 4 gigas de ram et 64
giga de stockage attention 64 giga de
stockage c'est pas du ssd si vous voulez
du ssd il faut passer sur la deux
une configuration qui coûte 100 euros de
plus 8 gigas de ram 128 go de stockage
c'est la version de test et franche
mentionné qu'il de vous recommander
c'est celle là elle est un peu plus cher
mais vous permettra d'aller un peu plus
loin de trancher un peu plus loin au
niveau des années à venir quoi qui est
super génial là dessus c'est l'écran
parce que l'écran pour l'instant je vous
ai pas encore parlé
vous avez un écran de 10 pouces et un
écran pixelsense mille 800 pixels par
1200 pixels et il à 217 et pays haut
niveau la vie chère graphique c'est une
intel hd graphics 615 toutefois sa
formation vous intéresse
lorsque vous voulez regarder des vidéos
sur youtube la qualité est franchement
bien c'est hyper agréable et justement
point extrêmement positif au dessus
c'est la qualité du son vous avez des
hauts parleurs stéréo avant
haut-parleurs là et on peut alors là du
coup on a un côté un peu plus immersif
justement la puissance audio on va aussi
la voir du côté du casque qui a un très
très très très gros volumes à
l'intérieur alors mais on va pas
forcément cherché à pousser à fond je
trouve que il y a du volume
il ya vraiment beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup de volume intérieur du casque
en plus de ça la qualité est là c'est le
rendu est plutôt hyper correct il ya un
énorme volume au niveau du casque est
aussi très bonne qualité donc ça c'est
aussi un point qui est extrêmement
positif parce que au final cette
tablette
parce que là on est en version tablette
elle va vous servir pour le côté un peu
un terme à une manne pour aller regarder
des films pour aller des séries pour
aller sur youtube pour écouter aussi de
la musique donc c'est très important il
faut pas négliger cet aspect là pour
vraiment profiter d'une expérience assez
immersive
le fait d'avoir les deux haut parleurs à
l'avancé un point qui est très très très
positifs et fait d'avoir une excellente
qualité au niveau du cast c'est aussi un
point qui est vraiment très très positif
au final on a un accessoire qui est une
tablette qui est un tablette graphique
et qui est aussi un ordinateur qui
permet d'avoir une bonne qualité vidéo
qui permet d'avoir une bonne qualité
audio
au final ça l'espèce de produits un
petit peu coûteux suisse peut faire
plein de choses avec oui et justement à
qui se destine ce produit et ça mon avis
c'est le point le plus intéressant
à la différence d'une surface pro qui
comme son nom l'indiqué est-il vraiment
un usage professionnel
une surface go se destine pour les
clients professionnels et du secteur
d'éducation je suis d'accord et pas
d'acord c'est à dire qu'effectivement la
surface go vase destiné aux
professionnels pour de là
prise de notes pour de la bureautique
pour du déplacement parce que c'est
vraiment un objet hyper hyper compact
vous l'emmener partout avec vous vous
levez c'est dans un sac à dos très
facilement c'est du 10 pouces ces tout
petits pour du déplacement professionnel
pour des commerciaux qui par exemple
doivent faire des rapports à faire du
excel word des logiciels derrière mais à
mon avis ce produit il destine surtout
au grand public et surtout aux côtés
éducation donc aux étudiants aux
étudiants parce que ça leur permet
d'avoir un outil qui ne fait pas du tout
de bruit vous n'avez pas avoir un
ventilateur qui tourne pour bosser par
exemple dans un amphithéâtre à la fac ou
dans une bibliothèque universitaire ou
que sais-je encore donc extrêmement
silencieux tout petit format vous
l'emmener partout avec vous vous avez
votre handicap fait faire des photos
sans vanité dans quelques instants avec
effectivement l'appareil photo ici vous
pouvez faire du skype de la visio
contrat avec l'appareil photo à l'avant
donc c'est vraiment un outil qui est
extrêmement flexible et on peut faire
beaucoup de choses avec
on peut aussi l'utiliser pour un usage
familial comme je vous le dis pour du
loisir regarder des séries mais des
dessins animés pour vos enfants
visionner des photos des souvenirs car
ce que vous voulez votre petit
bureautique votre compte à tout ce que
vous voulez vous pouvez le faire
directement là dedans donc c'est
vraiment un outil qui se destine à mon
sens au grand public aux étudiants et
aux professionnels qui n'ont pas besoin
d'avoir beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de
puissance à l'intérieur
côté hyper pratique c'est je vous le dis
dès son format qui est très compact
facile emmener partout je vous prends
ici un petit sac à dos format vraiment
mini mini mini sac-à-dos vous la glisser
dedans vous fermez vous l'emmenez où
vous voulez mais j'ai même pitié un sac
à ma femme se glissent extrêmement
facilement et là ça illustre vraiment le
côté très pratique portatif vous le
glisser partout vous en faites ce que
vous voulez et c'est en ça vraiment que
cette surface go est super intéressant
parce que c'est un ordinateur tablette
hybride que vous pouvez emmener partout
avec vous et ça c'est génial qu'est ce
qu'il en est de l'autonomie
parce que microsoft nous annonce une
autonomie allant jusqu'à 9 heures
bon 9h05 défend bien évidemment de votre
utilisation ce que vous allez faire
tourner si c'est un peu plus gourmand
pas gourmand moi j'utilise cette heure
sans problème je n'ai pas utilisé sept
heures non-stop comme ça a tapé à taper
à taper à taper donc monte est
effectivement on n'est pas forcément le
même que celui de microsoft ou j'imagine
qu'il doit avoir des process de test un
petit peu différents mais tous mis
bout-à-bout j'arrive à peu près à cette
heure d'utilisation sans avoir aucun
problème donc là c'est vraiment bien
parce que lorsque vous êtes une fois de
plus en déplacement que vous travaillez
à droite à gauche vous n'avez pas
forcément la possibilité de recharger
cette heure c'est quand même une bonne
autonomie et qu'en est-il de l' os dans
tout ça vous avez un windows disney vous
avez a surtout un windows 10 en mode s
alors quelle grosse différence par
rapport à windows 10 gt avec la grosse
grosse grosse grosse différence de
windows 10 en mode et drake la grosse
grosse grosse différence de windows 10
en mode s va situer au niveau du
microsoft store
toutes les applications vous allez
pouvoir installer sur les applications
qui ont été validés par microsoft dont
vous n'avez pas pouvoir installer
d'application d'éditeurs tiers dans la
mesure où vous êtes avec le windows 10
en mode s si vous voulez les installer
il faut switcher de windows 10 en mode s
à windows 10 par contre il sera
strictement impossible de faire machine
arrière
enfin quand vous avez une caméra de 5
mégapixels qui vous servira surtout pour
faire des visioconférences skype
franchement ça marche plutôt bien à
l'arrière vous avez une caméra de 8
mégapixels qui marche plutôt pas mal
vous avez dessus du hdr qui pouvait
activer désactiver vous avez quelques
petites options ici vous pouvez régler
vos proportion vos nombre de mégapixels
il ya pas mal de petites choses bon
c'est une petite caméra pour venir faire
quelques photos je dirais souvenir des
choses comme ça pour illustrer mais
c'est pas du tout une caméra
complètement ouf pouvait filmer jusqu'en
1080p et une fois de plus ça fera très
bien à faire vous avez également du
bluetooth 4 points et vous avez la
possibilité de rajouter une carte
microsd pour ni rajouté en stockage et
ça c'est plutôt cool pour moi cette
surface gohelle à deux usages principaux
le tout premier ça a effectivement de là
bureautique ça peut aussi être de la
bureautique plus pour des étudiants pour
venir travailler et aussi de la
bureautique et titre professionnel je
pense notamment on a une flotte de
commerciaux vous balader avec ça dans
votre sac ont pas beaucoup de place
c'est très pratique c'est extrêmement
flexible et ça pour bosser c'est aussi
un excellent outil et ça nous emmène au
deuxième usage qui est le côté loisir
pour regarder des vidéos de la musique
de tout ce que vous voulez ça marche
très bien pour résumer la surface ghost
un petit peu le chaînon manquant chez
microsoft il ya les gammes studio book
la top pros et maintenant il ya la gamme
bo qui est la gamme d'entrée de gamme en
tout cas la gamme de démarrage dans
cette gamme sur phrase qui est un
produit que je trouve vraiment très bien
si je dois avoir un point négatif ça
serait un petit peu le fil devoir
racheter tous les accessoires les uns
après les autres ça coûte quand même
relativement chaque par contre elle la
qualité est là je trouve que le produit
est super la surface go extrêmement
compliqué à comparer à une tablette
parce que c'est pas du tout son adn une
tablette c'est une tablette on peut lui
ravir tous les accessoires mais une
tablette reste une tablette les surfaces
go est un ordinateur est un hybride qui
est extrêmement polyvalente
on peut faire beaucoup de choses avec
néanmoins si vous devez l'acheter je
vous invite à aller sur la version 8
gigas de ram 128 go de stockage avec un
vrai ssd s'il voulait pas être limité
dans le temps
ça vous coûtera un peu plus cher par
contre vous serez pas déçus et
d'ailleurs si vous intéresse est sorti
ce gros je vous ai mis un lien en bas
dans la description et maintenant vous
de me dire ce que vous en pensez
j'attends tout vos commentaires dites
nous comment vous lui trouvez est-ce que
vous avez déjà eu des produits de la
gamme surface de microsoft est ce que
vous trouvez qu avec cette surface go
microsoft va dans le bon sens mark et
moi tout ça et on en parle directement
en bas dans les commentaires portez vous
bien chaud
[Musique]